the heading is inverse functions and
relations we really are going to be
focusing on the the functions as you'll
see why a little bit later but this
whole idea of inverse functions is a
really major idea it's interesting for
me I'm teaching it to you now because in
the past when we taught the extension
one course of which this is a part
because I know sometimes it kind of
blurs in your head like what's advanced
what's extension one this is extension
one but in the past in previous years
people learnt this topic much later like
a whole year later so we had a whole lot
of other stuff in our brains we're
learning it much earlier I think that's
actually a good thing because inverse
functions are actually things you've
been dealing with for many years we just
haven't really gave at that fancy name
so by doing it now we're gonna
understand better things we've been
doing for a long time and will hopefully
make sense of a few things you're like
why don't we do that and we just before
we'd say don't worry about it we'll get
to land up here we are at later okay now
I want to introduce you or reintroduce
you to probably the most famous inverse
function you know about actually feel
your calculator there could you get it
out please because if you think back to
you 9 you learn trigonometry in
right-angled triangles like this and for
example if you saw something like this
right right angled triangle like this
and you can see I've got onh labeling
well they stand for opposite hypotenuse
you know that that angle is related to
these two sides with a particular
function we give it a name that
particular function is opposite nine
points which was that one
it's sine right so in this particular
triangle you can say and you've got this
button on your calculator right you can
say sine of 30 degrees will give you
opposite online punished in this case
it's a half right but I'm just gonna
list it as that right so you can see
what whip inputting is an angle right
you input an angle and what do you get
out you get this ratio like this divided
by this right that's what you put in
that's what you get out okay but you
fairly quickly learned again back like a
couple years ago you fairly quickly
learned you could also do this in the
opposite direction right you could also
say hey if you know what the ratio is
you can find out what the angle is
right so what you do on your calculator
right you can see right above sign right
if you press shift you would not get
sign you would get ya inverse sine of
sine of s and it's got a arm it's got a
little symbol like that right so if you
say sign and we read that as inverse
right we don't read that as you know
when we did indices right if I gave you
this don't notice them if I gave you
this just the number you should say oh
that's index laws that's a quarter right
but here it just so happens we reuse the
same it's like in English how sometimes
we have a really good word we use it for
more than one thing we use this same
notation but it means something
dramatically different here it's like
undo what side did so if you put into
your calculator sine inverse all a half
it will faithfully hand back to you 30
degrees right so it gives you that that
angle whatever happens to be so in other
words what we're doing here is we're
changing perspective it's the same thing
it's the same object but from this
perspective I know what the angle is I
find out the ratio over here I know what
the ratio is and I'm turning things on
their head I'm getting out an angle and
your calculator 130 degrees okay
now this this sort of change in
perspective is very important it's why
these are actually called inverse
functions probably a word that you know
which is related to this is when you
turn something upside down we call that
will you invert it right turn it you're
looking at it from the opposite way
right so that's what these inverse
functions do they turn this thing
literally if you look at the angle ratio
ratio angle you're literally Taney's
upside down
and in fact that's an important point to
go from a function to the inverse
function this is worth writing down see
this input and output they swap the
input and the output to go from a
function the radial function to its
inverse you just swap the input and
Apple which may happen to be a ratio or
an angle or they could be anything right
so to think about what this means
algebraically right if you consider some
function f of X right for example sine
might be our f of X right the way to get
the inverse
and we're going to use the same notation
that you've seen from the inverse trig
functions right so see that minus one
I'm thinking of it meeting it's my
shorthand for saying inverse right so
instead of writing F I'm gonna write F
and then I'm gonna put up minus one so I
read this as the inverse of f of X right
so algebraically what do we do if you've
got this and you you want to get to the
inverse then you swap that's what we
just established right you swap the
inputs and outputs often the inputs are
called X's and the outputs are called
Y's right so case in point come and have
a look at these examples with it right
these are very very straightforward
functions that we know how to deal with
if I want to take these functions and
get an inverse out of them so if I want
to turn this guy into what's the inverse
this sort of undoes that you know this
guy will undo that what's going to undo
this right well I'm gonna swap the
inputs and outputs I'm going to swap the
X's and Y's so everything that I see
here I'm gonna rewrite but everywhere I
see an X I'll swap it for Y everywhere I
saw a Y swap it for an X so I'm going to
get instead of y equals I'll have x
equals 3y minus 1 now in theory I'm done
that thing there is the inverse function
of this but usually when we write
functions we like Y to be the subject
like I thought alway we always write it
right so let's just rearrange this just
a teeny bit to make Y this subject what
would you like me to do the both sides
first so if I if I subtract the Y it's
gonna I'm gonna have a minus 3y on this
side so it's kind of just like flopping
back and forth I'm sort of not really
that much closer to having Y by itself
is there something else I could do I've
got a couple of good options yeah okay
if I add one that's a little more
helpful because then I'm like oh this
thing which was here it won't be there
anymore
so I'm gonna add 1 to both sides that
gives me this and there's only one last
thing to do to get Y by itself I will
divide by 3 fantastic so I'm gonna also
switch sides at this points alright y
equals
at the front okay so this guy here is
the inverse of this one here right now
one of the reasons why we add this extra
notation F and F inverse is because
you're like well y equals this why cuz
that I'm gonna have lots of y equals
different things flying around and I
want to distinguish between them okay so
this y equals and this way cause are
inverses of each other
okay all right how about this one can we
do this one if we want to do the inverse
of this what's the first thing that I do
I wrote we wrote it down here I'm going
to yeah I'm going to swap those X's and
Y's right so the very first line is I'll
write everything like it was but instead
of y equals I'll have x equals y cubed
plus 2 okay again I start off with a
nice relatively simple one what's the
first thing I can do to get towards Y
being on it's no wiving the subject ya
recen alright we'll subtract 2 that
gives me this and at this point I've got
Y cubed I don't want Y cubed I just want
Y so what will I do to do the opposite
of that yeah I will take that said
against ya Justin do you okay yeah it's
it's like the square root but it's it's
cubed here not squared yet so it's the
cube root as you shouldn't point out so
I'm gonna swap sides as well I get this
mean happy with that right so this guy
is the inverse function of this